we want to get right to our special
coverage this morning as you know it
marks one year since the january 6 riot
we all remember it well it's one of
those days you'll always remember where
you were that day
five people died when hundreds of trump
supporters stormed the capitol trying to
stop certification of the election
results they did not succeed the assault
still divides americans though along
partisan lines unfortunately that is
very true lawmakers from both sides of
the aisle will remember that day here on
capitol hill but they will remember it
in very different ways in fact the
further we get from it the more
different they are but we want to go now
to cbs news's new congressional
correspondent scott mcfarland no
relation to seth macfarlane i am told
he's covered capitol hill for years
reported extensively on last year's
deadly attack and he joins us now scott
good morning quite an unusual day to
start
dan tony many democrats are going to
spend this day gathering right here for
speeches including from president biden
and for a prayer vigil former president
trump though has cancelled his plans to
speak from florida today
but there are republican lawmakers who
very much will be speaking publicly
about this anniversary florida
congressman matt gates georgia
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
both speaking here today both have been
critical of the prosecutions and the
pre-trial detention of some of the
accused rioters cbs news has learned as
of this morning of the nearly 700
federal defendants
39 of them
are in pre-trial jail here in d.c at the
jail just down the road including those
facing more serious charges like
conspiracy or those with
violent criminal histories
over the past year they've been spending
time awaiting trial but as it has in
courthouses across the country the
pandemic has made trial dates uncertain
and slippery over the past year they've
been waiting
and in recent days some house
republicans actually visited this jail
visited the january 6 defendants some of
whom are still awaiting those trial
dates there are also congressional
republicans who've been increasingly
critical of the justice department for
going harder they argue on january 6
defendants that on those arrested for
racial unrest in 2020 but in court
filings the justice department has been
emphatic
what happened here january 6 2021 was
unparalleled unprecedented a threat to
democracy and the peaceful transfer of
power tony
yeah well look alleged crime is an
alleged crime everyone deserves their
day in court and you want the system to
work rooting for the system to work here
in terms of democracy but also the
justice department and those
levers as well scott thank you very much
we'll see a lot i think in the years
ahead we appreciate it